Speaker 1: Let's now look at some of the guests
at this completely delusional Trump rally over
the weekend. We already looked at Trump's speech
in Florence, South Carolina. These are some of
my favorite clips. These are people who went to
the rally. I guess we kind of have to start with
he sort of just a guest at the end of the day.
MyPillow CEO and founder Mike Lindell. He was just
roaming around the fairgrounds or the campground
or whatever it is where they had the rally.
And he has some new claims about 2020.
It's not even worth introducing them.
Let's just listen to what he had to say.
Speaker 4: You know where the most votes in
the United States were sold? So anyone want to
guess California? One point five million votes
were stolen from Donald Trump. What, folks?
Speaker 1: They were stolen. They stole them,
and they are not giving them back a
Speaker 4: second in the nation. The tie between
Texas and Florida almost a million votes each.
OK, you can go for these red states from Alabama
and John Merrill, the Secretary of State there.
John, I'm coming for you. I'm coming for they're
coming back for the fourth time. We don't
know where, where all the crime was there
in the machines and stuff in Alabama.
One hundred and five thousand votes,
Ohio. One hundred and twenty thousand votes.
Donald Trump won. You want to hear what
states we know he won here. Here's the states
that Donald Trump won. This should be good.
He won. He won Minnesota, Wisconsin, Michigan,
Pennsylvania, New Hampshire, Georgia, Georgia,
Arizona and Nevada. You're right. We don't
know about. He might have won. Mean he might
have won Colorado. There's four others.
Speaker 1: Yeah, Colorado is a question
mark. You know, it's funny. Even if one point five
million votes in California were stalled, Biden
won there by 5.1 million votes. So as absurd,
it's like there's three layers of absurdity here.
As absurd as the claim is, about 1.5 million votes
being stolen or stolen, as I would say. For which
there's no evidence. It also wouldn't even change
the results in California. I don't know. Here is
probably my favorite clip from the rally. This
is a woman who has been dubbed G.G. the Greek
goddess. And she says communism is here in the
United States. Now, one of the things I love is
she and the interviewer agree communism is here,
but they don't agree about how it got here. This
is the I love when there's confusion like this.
Speaker 5: I'm watching your channel
jiji this the Greek goddess say that
communism is here because they asked
the American people are loud right now
to bring communism to this country,
Speaker 4: allowing it to come in this
country. We're not losing it right
Speaker 5: and we're allowed. This is the
Speaker 1: best, she says aloud. He says
we're allowing and then it just gets more
and more confusing. So what do they do? They
call for everyone to be imprisoned for treason.
Speaker 5: People, the Americans not to stand down
and fight for our country, that beautiful country
of ours. And yes, they stole our elections, right?
Dick Soros, the Democrat, the Republicans, the
Speaker 1: demon rats and Soros
stole the election. Guys, they stole
Speaker 5: all their stolen election.
Speaker 4: Swamp needs to go. Yes, right now. This
one, I love your shirt. There you go, Tara. OK,
all right. There you go.
Speaker 5: You OK? Don't be ashamed,
baby. Because your guy, the guy he is, more
than that, he needs to be in jail for treason.
All of them. Joy in the hall. Got to go.
Speaker 1: Yes, Biden put him in prison for
treason, she says. Then Trump's Trump's
endorsed candidate to fight against Nancy Mace.
Trump wants Nancy Mace out, and instead,
he's endorsed Kate Arrington. Here,
Kay Arrington gives us her four
policy priorities, so it's like, Oh,
hey, we're going to get some policy from
Republicans. That's cool. Let's listen.
Listen to her four priorities for
Speaker 6: the low country. First,
things we need to do when we get up there. Fire
Fauci. Second thing get rid of the Department
of Federal Education and third thing start
impeaching Biden and open Hunter Biden's laptop.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that these are her legislative
priorities. Fire Fauci, Fauci's 80 and I'm sure is
retiring soon. No. To get rid of the Department
of Education. This is the opposite of what we
need. We need to. We need to save American public
education. Impeach Biden. She doesn't say for what
and for. Open up Hunter Biden's laptop. Now, I
don't know if she means just like, turn it on and
open the lid, or if she means, like, take it apart
or just access the contents. It's not really clear
what what she means. And then lastly, just to
round out the tone and tenor of this wacky Trump
rally in South Carolina. Here's a guy who said he
refuses to wear masks so he's not flying because
if he flew, he would have to punch the stewardess.
Speaker 7: Wow, you're a man. That's
right. I try to get on a plane. I'll have
to also punch out the stewardess because
I'm not going to wear it right? All right.
Going to make the point that they all think
and I'm definitely not get vaccinated.
Rockets kill me first. I want to vaccinate.
So kill him.
Speaker 1: He'll he'll
die before he gets a vaccine and he'll punch a, he
says, stewardess. He'll punch a flight attendant
before he puts on a mask. So really,
the caliber of folks that are
they're not going ironically to the rally,
understand that if they went ironically,
it would be a totally different thing. But they
are unironically at the rally. We're going to take
a break. All of these clips will be on our
Facebook Facebook.com slash David Pakman show.